mais avec l'âge
colorier joe dassin l'amérique
l'amérique c'est bizarre je la chantais
dans le taxi et déjà il en a fait une bo
avec iam
on s'attendait pas c'est mon ami eric
loret mal en point grave fabien sait pas
faire ça
et
ouais
akhenaton faf larage twilight à
l'original du film de barry finch et sur
le coup voilà c'est moins fort que joe
dassin pour moi qui veut dire patrick
timsit c'est que l'américain le scénario
s'inspire de faits réels de votre vie
parce que depuis l'âge de 14 15 ans et
vécut ce serait un américain daily
régulièrement aux états unis vous aviez
une idée monde votre adolescence qui
était d'importer des skate board et
d'exporter de la ratatouille
voilà c'est vrai qu'on allait
régulièrement avec des potes aux états
unis qu'on avait ce rêve américain là
bas tout est possible une idée un dollar
et c'est possible et donc c'est vrai
qu'on ya cru et que et qu'on n'y était
tous les jours à chercher donc des des
idées un moment où les trois centres y
est la dernière idée c'était la
ratatouille j'étais avec fabrice nataf
mon copain ex patron de virgin
voilà aujourd'hui chez i buy et tout y
est on se réunissent et aux idées ont
pas on part en juin on parle beaucoup
rejoint pas été beaucoup d'allées la
fabriquer là-bas on s'est alors vu ses
favoris avaient mis cinq français du
commerce extérieur on était en quarts et
surtout on était un peu pointu avec rui
avec les béret maurice chevalier dans le
jukebox on va faire un bar français
qu'on va appeler la ratatouille et mon
rêve américain s'est arrêté là où le
film comment c'est à dire que francis
charge peut manger comme je vais
chercher le visa quoi ouais exactement
on se retrouve place de la concorde au
consulat d'amérique et on dit bah voilà
on a une idée on voudrait oui quoi eh
ben on voudrait exporter la ratatouille
on voudrait vivre là-bas très bien c'est
possible oui c'est possible
vous avez un père américain et d'une
mère américaine non un frère une soeur
peut-être lors un parent proche non vous
êtes marié à une américaine non c'est
pas possible alors et voilà on s'est
retrouvés un après midi de juin place de
la concurrence d'aérer les codes comme
francis fages dans le film et on avait
perdu 1,13 américain quoi parce que ça
en main mais çà mau qui vivait à los
angeles souvent est ce qu'on trouvera
toi tu vois là jamais personne
mr l'idée des femmes mortes jamais
personne l'a fait mais là ça va donner
les il ya des gens qui vont déposer le
broker attend les croissances
apparaissait aussi qu'aujourd'hui à
plein de croissanterie ouais c'est
impressionnant oui voyez je suis malade
non mais tu aurais fait fortune dans
était de gagner plus devenu qu'avec le
cinéma c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui je
vendrai la ratatouille a le sens de
gérer alors destin qu'il faut choisir
c'est un enjeu la sortie de ce film pour
vous l'envié se stresser un peu pataud
mais alors pas du tout mais pas du tout
pas du tout pas du tout serait prenez
des risques a grandement hockey m'a dit
une fois une femme géniale il ya
beaucoup de risques à ne pas prendre de
risques
oui exactement alors je maintiens ouais
c'est vrai que tant qu'on croit qu'on
est dans le registre on prend moins de
risques quand on pense qu'il ya pas de
risque à la et bien non il ya un
proverbe génial c'est les bateaux sont à
l'abri dans les ports mais ne sont pas
fait pour cela
ah ça reste va là pour moi absolument je
préfère casser en mer il ya risque vous
pouvez plus en tous les cas c'est celui
de venir sur les plateaux télé quoi on
nous voit plus le début de votre
carrière du titre et généreux et de la
télé vous étiez là j'ai marc et moi la
première fois que j'ai eu un fou rire
sur un plateau de télé c'est un double
jeu avec patrick et avait les noirs qui
tenaient les hallebardes comme ça il a
retouché les couilles et c'est la
première fois où je me suis marré et je
me suis dit [ __ ] mais je me suis dit
je me suis dit mais c'est un boulot on
peut rire en le faisant parce que jusque
là je fais encore plus sérieusement que
maintenant et je me suis dit on peut
rire en le faisant ils essaient voilà ça
a été vraiment pour moi une révélation
cette émission et je puis on vous a plus
jamais beaucoup vu mais est ce que c'est
moi qui ai changé ou la télé qui a
changé non c'est vous parce que vous
êtes chez vous
d'après la tribune vous connaissez pas
vous avez 20 minutes et la souche et les
couilles de personnes non cvs kamanzi
patrick amand vous étiez profession
invités c'est vrai si vous dites les
gens pensent que je fais que invités à
la tv qu'est ce que je faisais donc je
vais faire autre chose il vous avez
rompu complètement les ponts avec
l'athénée trop parce qu'il est pas
question non plus de venir soient tous
les jours soit jamais donc là vous avez
commencé à plus jamais venir
il ya eu une rupture d'affectivité avec
le public vous le savez ça avait avec le
public télé voulait dire non le public
en général le public annonce peut-être
pas si je suis si le public a cru que
voulez-vous le seul objet presque faux j
n est pas là qu'il faut prendre sa place
ainsi nous mêmes un raid même quand même
gérant veut nommer de façon à oui c'est
ça je sens non je crois qu'ils n'ont pas
déconner avec moi non mais sérieux c'est
parce que vous nous manquez avec plaisir
à 6 et une déclaration d'amour si je
viens c'est bien sûr c'est ça
1 c'est la grande réconciliation sociale
non mais c'est bon ça je prends bien mon
nom mais ce n'est que ça ça mais que ça
ok vous avez peur de quoi en menant la
télé de vous banalisez de vous tous qui
est rare est précieux il a raison de se
protéger
vous avez peur de quoi ça suffisait en
couple j'avais peur d'un dérapage a pas
du tout dans un menu dérapages puisque
en général c'est moi qui les provoque
je devais vous n'êtes pas peur de
déraper oui mais dieudonné dérape pas
hanter les idées à entre les télés nous
étonner moi j'ai jamais vu qu'il avait
dérapé en télé j'ai vu quelqu'un qui l'a
fait déraper en télé votre avis comment
et sa belle dans cinq ans le bouquin non
mais c'est vrai j'avais peur de quoi
vous n'êtes pas peur de déraper vous
diriger sa part le terrain j'ai peur de
ne plus rien avoir à raconter j'aime
bien venir ici à dans la patate
et puis tout d'un coup un peu
déstabilisé avoir des choses à 1 si vous
en fais tous les jours vous vous répétez
il ya un truc et vous devenez bon client
est bon client de quoi qu'est ce que
laurent blanc est ce que vous êtes
heureux vous de faire date et les
devenir un td oui ça va c'est ça ma
façon on vous dit que ce sera toujours
plus agréable que métier de votre père
ouais ben forcément et on a moins les
doigts dans la merde oui il est plombier
ces éléments obligé des bouchers des
trucs donc c'est forcément quelque chose
de de plus gratifiant même si c'est un
métier qui est qui est très nécessaire
et surtout en ce moment où l'on chauffe
eau à péter et on essaie bien les
cordonniers molière chaussée parce que
j'ai envie de faire une annonce pour mon
père
si tu pouvais venir la semaine prochaine
je commence vraiment l'avoir la crèche
aux gauchos 100 litres je peux pas le
sortir tout seul où il a encore plein
rêve
ah oui heureusement vous marier ouais
faire l'amour déjà
j'aimerais donc j'ai poussé le menu elle
nous a raconté les a racontés les
pendentifs confusion là si ça vous voilà
quelques jours je me suis venu chercher
laurent n'importe laquelle une
consentante
ouais déjà et non non je crois que j'ai
trouvé un way être je suis très épris
jeu sous le patrie qui avec sa en
permanence
donc voilà vous êtes sur une bonne piste
ça va ya pas vous êtes l'homme dans sa
maîtresse et prix malheureusement je ne
crois pas que ce soit forcément partagé
mais à mais on est plein de rêves
donc on bosse et puis les le principal
dans un rêve c'est pas forcément d'y
arriver mais c'est de courir pour
l'atteindre
si vous avez le prix jean gabin ouais
j'ai peut-être dû lui dire la tête dû le
savoir mais ça n'allait pas trop là
dedans et pas trop branché s'il a payé
le prix jean gabin
thierry lhermitte en main
m
j'entends variable
pour moi des vols vers l'ouest salaire
pour nous autres les enfants
oui répondeur